From the man responsible for every movie your
girlfriend tried to drag you to
comes the film responsible for every bad movie
about a dozen famous people falling in love
on a popular holiday...
Love Actually
This holiday season, prepare for the ultimate
romantic comedy
that's not very romantic
or funny
or relevant to the holiday season.
"They've been giving out parts in the nativity
play!"
"And I'm the lobster!"
"In the nativity play?"
But don't worry: sit through it and you
still might get laid.
Follow along on this Pulp Fiction for girls,
stuffed with eight different plot-lines that
are creepy and depressing when you actually
stop to think about them, like...
a man getting over the death of his wife by
helping his kid seduce a girl with the same
name as his dead mom,
"Her name's Joanna?"
"Same as mom."
a woman who ends up alone with her unstable
brother instead of her hot available coworker
"Don't do that, my darling."
this guy who's trying to bang his best friend's
wife...
wait, is that Rick?
"Do you think Carl knows?"
"Caaaaaarl!"
"Carl!"
a man who will throw away his loving wife
and children to buy a
necklace for this walking vagina,
"Full of dark corners for doing dark deeds."
a powerful older man who fires his subordinate
for being distractingly hot,
a powerful older man whose wife cheats on
him...
so he seduces his young hot subordinate who
doesn't even speak English,
and these two uncomfortable stand-ins on the
highest budget porno of all time.
Experience what boils down to a supercut of
every rom-com cliche in the book, like
the last minute airport dash,
"Sam?"
"I thought you didn't know my name."
awkward meet cutes,
"It's Junction 13. That's just murder, isn't
it - total gridlock this morning."
making out behind the curtain and getting
discovered,
singing in public,
"Good King Wenceslas looked out."
adorable children,
"I'm in love."
Over the top gestures,
"All you need is love!"
and Hugh f***ing Grant.
So this Christmas, catch one of the most subversive
chick flicks of all time
that's aimed at a female audience
but tells them the ideal woman brings you
food,
"These are... for you."
"Banoffee pie."
isn't fat,
"The chubby girl?"
"He said I was gettin' fat."
"Come on later, Plumpy."
"I think there's a pretty sizable ass
there, yes. Huge thighs."
and shows you her boobs.
Thanks, bro!
Starring...
all these people you likes better in other
things.
Rick. For real! I'm telling you, that's totally
Rick.
Bilbo Baggins from The Hobbit
Qui-Gon Jinn
Hans Gruber
Davy Jones
Kim Bauer
Professor Trelawney
Liz Shaw from Doctor Who
Nadia from American Pie
Betty Draper
Xerxes
Carmen from Starship Troopers
Bad Santa
Oh of course Mr. Bean's in it
Jojen Reed
Elizabeth from Pirates of the Caribbean
and the voice of Marceline on Adventure Time
Wow. All that's missing is someone from
Breaking Bad...
Oh sh*t!
It's the Grey Matter guy from Breaking Bad!
Bingo! I have Bingo!
Sh*t Actually
"This is sh*t, isn't it?"
"Yup! Solid gold sh*t, maestro!"
Exactly.